welcome to other famous Friday I believe
that whatever goal whatever a challenge
you have in front of yourself somebody
has already accomplished it and the best
way to go out and achieve that goal for
yourself is to model their success and
apply it to your business so today's
lesson is from Mark Burnett the king of
rally TV and his lesson is jump in now
this is actually a special classes the
first time we've done a special request
on the channel it came from with my
youtube viewers love you guys
the Lowe's ed 180 who wrote in to say
good stuff
don't ever stop the success stories I
love them do you have anything on Mark
Burnett I don't have anything on Mark
Burnett yet but it's a great story I've
read his book I think you should watch
the channel because something soon might
be coming on Mark Burnett soda Lowe's ed
180 this is for you now Mark Burnett was
born in London he grew up as the son of
factory workers at the Ford plant his
parents worked at the Ford mortar plant
making cars and when he was young
growing up he didn't know what he wanted
to do he didn't know where his path
would lie he just felt like he had the
jump in on opportunities and see where
it took him and so at 17 he joined the
British Army and he joined as a
parachute jumper and instead of just
jumping into opportunities he was
jumping out of planes and like most
young people you know he didn't know
what he wanted to do yet so he was just
exploring he discovered that you know
what the army wasn't the life for him
and at 22 he decided I'm gonna leave the
UK I want to go to America I don't know
what I'm gonna do there I don't I have
nothing lined up but I'm gonna jump in
on this opportunity I'm following my
passion I'm following my flow it feels
like the right thing to do I'm jumping
in and I'm going to America well the
only opportunity he could land was being
a nanny and a chauffeur so he was a
nanny for these two boys in California
can you imagine you just come from from
being in the military your paratrooper
your jumping out of airplanes you go to
America and now you're
Nannie earning $250 a week but it didn't
matter for him because he jumped into
the opportunity and he's gonna find a
way to make it work he knew that that
wasn't gonna be a long-term thing but by
going to America he would find out what
his true calling would be from there he
got hired by the Father the two boys
after proving himself to be reliable and
trustworthy the father of those two boys
worked at an insurance company and
brought him on board and Mark now was in
the insurance business he jumped in he
said yes he had no idea what about
insurance but he jumped in and learned
about it from there he discovered an
opportunity to sell t-shirts on Venice
Beach and he rented a small section of
fence at Venice Beach to sell t-shirts
for $18.00 a shirt and he said yes I
mean he jumped in they started doing
that and he found out he can make more
money selling t-shirts and selling
insurance so that became his full-time
thing and then his life really changed
dramatically when he decided to enter an
adventure race in France where he was
racing through the mountains and through
all of these crazy back-breaking
exercises that he had to go through in
order to win the race and he loved it so
much reminded him of his paratrooper
days that he said I gotta bring this to
America he bought the TV rights for it
and brought it to the States and called
it eco-challenge
and that was his first foray into
television production and so here's this
guy who has had no experience in TV
right he didn't go to school for it he
did mentor under somebody he didn't have
a job for ten years learning it he just
said I'm jumping in I'm gonna learn this
thing I have my passion I'm gonna figure
it out
I'm gonna make it a success he bought
the rights having never done anything in
TV before and turned it into a success
now eco-challenge became a cult hit I
believe is on the Discovery Network and
they had his fan base and led him to
create his next opportunity which was
survivor and that really blew him up
right he went from survivor he created
The Apprentice he created sharks tanks
on my favorite shows he's now been
nominated for over 100 Emmys and he's
just still getting started right he's
still young he's still got a huge runway
in front of him this is a really
important lesson for you guys watching
because if you don't know what your next
step should be right if you don't know
what your passion is you don't know what
your end goal is yet you're still trying
to figure it out that's okay that's a
lot of people and your best option is to
jump in get in there try it out learn if
you like it keep doing it and get better
at it if you don't switch and jump to
something else and it's scary and it's
hard and it pushes you because you don't
know what you're gonna be doing every
day and that uncertainty is is troubling
and it's not the smart thing to do but
look at what is the smart thing right
what do most people do with their lives
right they they go to school they
graduate they get a job they stay in
that industry for 40 years and then
retire and and they hate their job they
hate going to work they're living for
the evenings and weekends that's the
smart thing to do that doesn't sound so
smart to me the best thing to do is
follow your flow follow what you're
passionate about jump in on something
you're excited about it jump in and try
it out see if it works see if you love
it if you do keep going go deeper and if
you don't go to something else and
eventually I promise you you'll find
something that you love that makes you
complete that makes you feel like your
success it makes you feel like you're
contributing back just like Mark Burton
Burnett did he went from army to jump
into the u.s. to jump in into being an
enemy and a chauffeur making $250 a week
to jump into insurance to jump into
selling t-shirts to jumping to adventure
races to then jumping into TV production
and he found this home there and he
ended up writing a book which is an
awesome book I recommend it called what
else
jump in
so believe in yourself take a chance on
yourself and you've seen an opportunity
that makes you come alive jump in on it
believe thanks for the request I hope
you like that video for those of you
watching you want to see more just like
it you can subscribe to the channel
thank you so much guys I'll see you soon
if you want more believe energy running
through your veins sign up for the
newsletter below it's free you're gonna
love it
hi I'm Jason Grif on seeker Roselyn calm
and I want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and it's the only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period